let's find out lifting is it gay wanting
to impress dudes more than chicks here's
some hard facts for you girls get
dressed up to impress other girls and
guys get jacked to impress other guys no
guy gives about the ,000 purse that you
stuff with garbage and no chick gives a
about your vascular forearms that look
like an anime drawing of a monster the
only people who truly appreciate the art
of sculpting the male body are dudes and
we now know thanks to the dad bot play
that girls will literally a ziplock bag
filled with gravy cuz it makes them feel
Superior so you ain't killing yourself
in the gym for them you do it for the
Bros and the gay guys do it with the
Bros it's a different show but it is the
same audience so I guess this one goes
in the center here yeah yeah sums it up
that's why I don't go to the gym ever
makes me a super straight